that should do it
oh it's working welcome I'm so glad you
could be here with us today to try out
my latest invention interact Oh vision
Austin Gromit - most people probably
already know are an English comedy duo
who are the stars of a series of clay
mated shorts and what we're doing is
we're made a series of games which are
designed to feel like four more shorts
in this series and it's actually they're
they're connected to each other but each
one has has its own story and they come
out come out on a monthly more or less
monthly basis well on XBLA and and also
on our own website el tiempo so the idea
is basically that you are guiding the
main characters of kind of a little
movie so you get to be Wallis for a
while and you cause problems and then
you get to be Gromit for a while and you
get yourself out of problems and we
generally kind of go back and forth
between you get to be Wallis you get to
be Gromit the way we wanted to approach
sort of taking the claymation
stop-motion style and turning into a
video game was something that we we put
a lot of effort into we we played around
with our frame rate since since our
games a little slower paced we were able
to sort of slow that down a bit we also
did some some sort of under the hood
systemic stuff with with the way the
characters move to get their movements
to interpolate and differently and feel
a little bit more like stop-motion we we
set the the changing mouths on the
dialogue for the characters when they
talk their mouths don't interpolate much
so they they kind of step a little bit
and and that's that kind of adds to it
so all those things kind of mix together
give you this sense you know that even
though the cameras flowing at 30 frames
a second and everything else is flowing
at 30 frames a second it feels a little
bit closer to you know a 24 frames per
second stop-motion film
I've been really required that we
replicate their characters dead on so we
took a lot of great pains replicating
replicating that in terms of modeling
the way the characters bend and move the
the texture and they they were nice
enough to give us some of their their
actual examples and these are the these
are sort of the prototypes that they
used when you know going in and shaping
the mouths for the film's it was a
challenge to get to figure out a way to
have Wallace convey what what it was
you're supposed to do in the world in
terms of how he moves so he has to walk
around he has to look at things he has
to pick things up and do all of that
sort of simultaneously and that's maybe
a little different than the the very
specific acting that we're used to
seeing Wallace do in the films you know
he's pretty much just doing his thing
now he's got to sort of hang out but
also you know check out what's around
and focus on things and and so that that
was a definite sort of concession to
interacting in the game environment
wallace and gromit have a whole new town
that that you that you get to deal with
and a whole new set of characters and
you know some people who are friends
some people who are foes some people who
are unwelcome antagonists and and yeah
we were able to to sort of populate
populate their world with with some new
and very interesting characters and I
think that that was fun for everyone
involved in that process from the from
the writers to the the designers to the
modelers so the animators being able to
to take on you know something new in the
in the Wallace & Gromit Canon and and
sort of make it their own
and I think people will be very very
pleased with what some of the characters
that they're introduced to over the
course of this series